given the seven days we've had it's
international women's week
with public anger great public anger at
the place of women in society
what were the police thinking last night
well first of all can i just reflect on
the fact that this has been
an unimaginable week for
the family and friends of sarah everard
the the
loss that they are suffering is beyond
our comprehension
and i think in response to that the
reaction that we've seen
from women across the country in terms
of their
own experiences of sexual harassment
in the street and violence and being
frightened to walk in our streets
is also very very shocking and very very
upsetting
and so last behaved the way they did
it through the day we saw many people
come to that particular part of clapham
common to
pay their respects to lay a flower
around the banstead
and of course the majority of them
had a peaceful experience now the scenes
that we've seen
later on in the day in the evening are
very upsetting
and i i take it very seriously the home
secretary
takes it very seriously which is why she
has asked the metropolitan commissioner
for a report on what has happened last
night
take a look at this image if you're able
to um
it's the image of the young girl who is
on the ground with the police officers
on top of her
is that the state of british policing
today
i i you'll have to forgive me i don't
have a screen here but i imagine
i hope i'm thinking of the right
photograph because i've seen
the photograph both on social media and
of course in newspapers
and and that photograph is something
that the police will have to explain
in their report to the home secretary i
think
any policing of large events is
is difficult at the best of times but
we're in the middle of a pandemic with
all of the
rules that flow from that and of course
last night people were very very upset
there was a great deal of emotion
completely understandably
and the police being as they are
operationally independent
will be having to explain that to the
home secretary in their report
i mean you say it's difficult to police
in a pandemic
if we think back to the images that we
saw a week ago
when uh there were football celebrations
in the streets up in glasgow after
rangers win
hundreds and hundreds of men walking
through the streets
essentially just being allowed to by the
police
this was a very small group of women who
were confined onto a bandstand
i was there it was cold it was dark
people were petering away what was the
what was the rationale behind going in
to to stop that
well as i say um it is for the police to
make
these decisions uh often in the moment
when they're policing major events
but i i'm pleased that you were able to
go i myself chose to
take part in the virtual vigil we found
i hope between us we found many
different ways of marking
our respect and marking our concerns
about the issues that have been raised
this week
but as i say the home secretary has
required
a report from the met commissioner to
look into these
and that's right because the police have
to be operationally independent i don't
think anyone would want
a scenario whereby politicians are
directing the police
but it is also right that they are held
to account
by democratically elected politicians
and that they explain
their actions to the wider public and
indeed just today
i've seen that the borough commander has
acknowledged
on social media that last night was very
difficult they're in a very difficult
place at the moment
and so i do hope that we'll be hearing
uh explanations
uh in the hours and days to come i mean
another report pretty patel says
i mean i can tell you that the woman
there last night didn't want another
report they wanted something done
do you think our police force is sexist
do you think what you saw last night was
sexist policing
well actually if i may just just take
you up on that point about action
um we in response to the outpourings
of anger and experiences that we've
heard this week
on friday we reopened
the public survey that has been feeding
into and shaping
our new forthcoming national strategy
on tackling violence against women and
girls this was this is the largest ever
survey that's ever been conducted to
tackle violence against women and girls
and already by the time of the deadline
we had 15
000 responses from members of the public
i'm really pleased to say that since we
reopened it
at 6 00 pm on friday we've had a further
000 responses from the public so look if
you want change if you want your voices
to be heard
we are listening and please please put
your
views your experiences into the public
survey if you look at the
uk website it's there please tell us
your views and experiences because then
you can help us shape
this strategy that we're creating and
that will be published later this
year but there will be there will be a
lot of there will be a lot of women
saying and saying that these are simply
platitudes you know we're going to talk
to vera bird in a short while the
victims commissioner
she has put together a number of reports
about failings in the criminal justice
system
in the police service towards women it's
another report isn't it
british patel is the home secretary has
she not got any ideas of her own why is
she asking the whole population to come
up with a strategy for her
this is a problem women in society
and the levels of crime that they are
victims to that we are
well aware of we need action not more
research
and in fairness you have seen action
from this government at the moment we
have the domestic abuse bill
going through parliament i have led on
that this is a groundbreaking piece of
legislation
that is really changing the way that
victims of domestic abuse are treated
and in addition perpetrators of domestic
abuse are treated
this is real action that will have a
huge impact
on the 2.3 million victims of domestic
abuse that we know
live in this country but that is in
violence in the home
the next step now is for us is us
looking at violence
on the street and other forms of
violence against women and girls
there is a huge range of different
crimes that disproportionately affect
women and girls from
sexual harassment in the streets through
to fgm forced marriage
and stalking the government is
absolutely working on all of this
and the national strategy that is being
published this year
is because we want to set this for
local commissioners the police councils
etc across the country we want
this to be the the guide if you like um
to tackling these sorts of crimes i
really don't think it's fair
to uh to make those allegations that
you're making i totally understand why
in the spirit and the emotion of the
moment
this week that the people are thinking
that but believe you me this comes from
the very top the prime minister
is personally committed to this the home
secretary is and i am
this is a huge piece of work and we want
to listen to members of the public my
goodness
if we weren't listening to members of
the public i think you would rightly be
criticizing us
actually and some of the experiences
that we've heard this week
absolutely must be reflected in our
national strategy going forward
well let's move away from as you say the
spirit and the emotion of the week let's
just look at
brutal facts over the last 11 years of
the conservative government
the rate of rape so this isn't that the
rate of this is
the rape of rape charges so this isn't
people going to court being found guilty
or not guilty
it's the percentage of people who
actually get charged by a police officer
with rape it's 1.4 percent that's
happened under the conservative
government
in the last couple of weeks anthony
williams given a five-year sentence for
throttling his wife in lockdown
apparently he just flipped also
uh in the last couple of weeks a man was
spared jail after dragging a woman to
the ground and molesting her
part of his defense in court was if he
went to jail he would lose his
job these are crimes against women and
women look at what happens when they
report crimes and they say that this
government
this police force this justice service
isn't serving
us and we hear
we absolutely hear that and what is more
we want it to change which is why
as part of uh on top of the work that
we're doing with the domestic abuse bill
and the
tackling violence against women girls
strategy we are also conducting an
in-depth review into the criminal
justice system from
end to end when it comes to rape and
sexual assault investigations
there are it is absolutely in depth i
mean two of the examples you've given
there
the sentence and the well both of the
sentences of course those are matters
for judges the judiciary are independent
of government
but that has not stopped us looking at
their role in the course of this
end-to-end
rate review it is absolutely critical
that
uh every single part of the criminal
justice system plays
its role in ensuring that perpetrators
are brought to justice
and by way of uh example only tomorrow
we are bringing forward the police crime
sentencing and courts bill
and one of the most important measures
in that as far as i'm concerned
is that we will be increasing the
minimum sentence
that serious and violent offenders serve
in prison
at the moment they're let out at half
halfway through their sentence
we're increasing that to two-thirds
because we absolutely
understand the public's horror that
violent and sexual offenders should be
let out of jail at an early stage in
their sentence so that is just one
example we're also making
very real change changes to what are
called sexual harm prevention orders
and sexual risk orders these are orders
that can be imposed either when someone
has been convicted
or when uh they if there there hasn't
been a conviction at all in the
case of sexual risk orders these orders
help the police to manage
these uh sexual offenders and and we're
going to make
these orders even tougher so we're going
to require for example
where appropriate that offenders have to
undertake positive requirements as part
of
the order so there's a huge amount of
work going on on this because we
absolutely
understand and recognize public concern
about this and we want to
deal with it um
you're the safeguarding minister you
will will know these figures but if
you're a police officer accused of
domestic violence you're less likely to
be convicted
compared to the general population
around 3.9 percent of
police officers are convicted compared
to around 6.2 percent of those in the
general population
i mean some would say that both of sets
of those figures are pretty low
do you think the police as it is at the
moment should be investigating their own
do you think we need changes there
well we have a we've got a training
programme
called domestic abuse matters which is
being rolled out across
police forces primarily to help them
support victims and investigate some of
the most
difficult domestic abuse crimes that
exist so um
we we know we long know that people in
the past have tended to think of
domestic abuse as perhaps
physical violence sadly we know it is
not restricted to physical violence and
it can include
coercive controlling behavior and the
many many forms in which that can
be deployed and what we have found is
that as this training has been rolled
out not only
have the conviction rates in those force
areas
very much improved but also that police
officers themselves
have either realized that they
themselves are victims of domestic abuse
or they are worried about their own
behavior
and so i've always said you know the
bill this is a landmark piece of
legislation i mean we
in the bill itself um we are we've
responded to the concerns for example
about
the increase in non-fatal strangulation
we're prohibiting that in this bill
we've responded to the concerns about
threats to use revenge porn we've put
that in the bill
and we have responded to the concerns
about
the so-called rough sex defense these
are all issues that affect women
not just in personal relationships but
in uh
when they're out on dates and so on and
so what we've wanted with this bill is
to
really really start a conversation about
abusive behavior
and what we can do to support victims
but also to tackle perpetrators
and in on the last matter what we're
doing is investing
unprecedented amounts of money now in
perpetrator programs
because we want to stop that cycle of
abuse and so
i think you know we really are at a
turning point when it comes to
the way in which we as a country are
dealing with
crimes that disproportionately affect
women and girls i think this week is a
really significant
moment i think that you know the
experiences of women that have been
expressed
have been absolutely um shocking i think
a lot of
men have not quite realized what their
loved ones their sisters their
girlfriends theirs their wives have gone
through and i genuinely believe this
could be a moment of change
well a lot of people would welcome that
certainly i mean let's let's
roll back to last night and the scenes
we saw
uh there's been a lot of criticism of
the policing uh also criticism of
cressida dick
the lib dems calling for her to go
kierstama saying that the images are
deeply disturbing
i'm just thinking of the met and and
putting the sarah everett case aside
uh in terms of police but you know we
had that case not that long ago with
police taking
selfies of themselves with dead women's
bodies
do you think cressida dick really needs
to go now
well in terms of that incident i mean i
think everyone was
horrified by that including the met
commissioner and those officers were
dealt with very quickly
um i i i really really want uh
to support the home secretary in her
um request to have a report for cressida
um
the the the police have got a tough job
in policing the coronavirus pandemic
more generally at the moment i think you
know we time to be taking selfies with
themselves should they if you know
they're dealing with a pandemic they're
dealing with all of this
it just doesn't seem that their
priorities are in the right place in the
right place
well i if i may i wouldn't want an
entire
um the entire police force across the
country the 43 peace forces to be tarred
with those incidents um i i you know
the police officers i've had the
pleasure of working with not just as a
as a minister but in my previous role
prosecuting criminals
um you know that that is not behavior
that is um
that i've ever ever clearly um witnessed
so i i just i think
this morning given how difficult
last night was after what has been an
incredibly upsetting week
i just i'm very keen that we don't
preempt
the fine you know that report uh and
that we
we give the met commissioner a chance to
explain what happened last night
you think she should explain you think
there is a potential that she may go
so the home secretary has asked for a
report so
and i think that's appropriate you know
the police are operationally independent
but it's right that
they explain their their actions to the
home secretary
particularly in the very very um
difficult circumstances of this week so
um you know i think we've got to take
this step by step this morning and
again i'm just very conscious that for
the family and friends
of sarah everard this is this is not
what anyone
uh wanted and certainly if people who
took part in the virtual vigil
people who were there in peace people
who were laying their flowers
this is this is not what any of us
wanted and i
i very much hope that we will be
talking about the much more positive
steps that we can and will be taking to
tackle violence against women and girls
through the government survey
and other work the